i had a fellow who uh criticized my
science series and i'm addressing some
of the issues he raised okay
one by one and i addressed a couple of
them already today i'm going to be
addressing a third segment here
something this fellow said
so let's just
roll on see what this fellow had to say
give me a second here so that i can turn
this on here it goes listen carefully
the questions and issues addressed in
this rebuttal are
is science an ongoing process
is the problem in science today that the
mathematicians don't yet have all the
answers
you know the wording there is quite
important it says we don't know the
complete answers to these questions and
that is why science is an ongoing
process because yeah we have some of the
answers but we don't have all of the
answers
okay i'll address first the second part
okay
whether we have all the answers okay and
that'll lead probably to a reply uh an
answer to the first one the the issue is
you know whether um
we have any answers today and the answer
i can give you is that we have no
answers today from the mathematical
establishment
okay what kind of answers are people
looking for or some of the answers that
people are looking for that have not
been addressed in 2 500 years at least
since the days of the greeks
and here are
just a rundown on that so that you can
see what i'm talking about okay
uh we have not a single answer uh do we
know what gravity is
what causes gravity
you know here i always do my famous
experiment okay and get the pencil here
we let go of the pencil and it falls
down
and you see nothing here and you see
nothing here you touch nothing here
nothing here other than there right
which is not meant to be a cause of of
gravity okay so we let go of the pencil
and falls to the ground
nobody can tell you what causes that to
happen
two thousand five hundred years no one
can tell you what causes that to go down
and i addressed that the other day you
know uh this all thinks that space time
and the first thing there is that you
know space-time works out there
space-time in other words the general
relativity theory which is not a theory
it's just a mathematical description has
to do with giant masses
it doesn't have to do with warp space
being you know space being warped down
here at this level
a lot of people don't understand that
okay that's one issue but here uh what
is the explanation well here it is okay
this is from brian green okay this is so
you can look it up okay it's not not me
putting this uh you know raising
strawman or whatever here it is this is
this is the mechanism why the moon
doesn't fly out of the solar system why
it doesn't fly out of the earth orbit
okay so uh
is this the mechanism we're saying
there's a warped canvas there meaning
warp time because that's what that
canvas is those lines there they
represent time
one of those okay one of those lines so
we have warp time and here's the
mechanism they propose i've shown this
the other day okay
is that what we have we have warp time
is that what's preventing the moon from
flying out or the earth from flying out
of the solar system a curved wall of
time
it's the roulette mechanism and so this
is what we have today and what can you
say are are you going to believe that
this is what causes gravity
so this is an irrationality mainly
because they're doing it with concepts
this is not a physical description or or
even mechanism explanation for why the
earth or the moon don't fly out of the
solar system or for that matter any
other planets asteroids and whatever why
do why do they all revolve around the
sun
what keeps them there what is the
centripetal force that you know pulls
them towards the sun while the thing is
trying to
you know orbit and get out of the
sun's orbit okay so this is the issue
the issue is that they have no
explanation for gravity how about
magnetism i covered that the other day
as well you can look it up in more
detail than today okay and here you have
a magnet and it's uh in the water and
you can see that the magnet is pulling
one iron filing at a time towards it so
in that region called a field magnetic
field uh as mr um
faraday and and mr james maxwell both
said you know that in that region you
have matter in motion they cannot
conceive of you know that region being
without some kind of exotic matter and
there's something in motion in there so
because you can see it's pulling one
magnet at one iron filing at a time so
how do you explain this and you know
again what they say is that the
the that the um what is it the domains
are aligned that's what they that's one
of the answers they give you domains are
aligned as i discussed the other day the
other one that they say is that the
electrons are spinning clockwise or
counterclockwise so what so they're
spinning clockwise counterclockwise the
domains are aligned how does that in any
way shape or form
uh pull on one of those iron filings
right through the water towards the skin
of the magnet that's what you got to
explain so we have no explanation for
magnetism
and
none for gravity how about electricity
are we doing any better with electricity
does anybody on planet except us here
understand how electricity works okay
let's find out here this is electricity
according to the establishment here you
see it okay you have a circuit on the
left okay and they say it's the rolling
of beads from atom to atom and there you
see it on the upper right the big atom
blue blues are the atoms the
uh red ones are the electron beads and
what we're doing here is simulating with
hydrogen atoms essentially and what
they're saying is that um what
electricity is simply the flow of
electron beads from atom to atom and
that's essentially the
model also used by uh albert einstein
essentially you know
to explain the photoelectric effect that
he said there's these charges
and um
that are being hit by photons during the
photoelectric effect and that's what
electricity is so everybody agrees that
this is what electricity is this is how
uh the electric universe also explains
electricity the flow of charges as they
call it and the problem with all this is
that atom on the bottom right
if you are going to explain
uh ionization if you're going to explain
quantum jump if you're going to explain
electricity you're using that planetary
atom that you see on the bottom right
okay and so the only issue there that
the person has to explain is why doesn't
the electron bead fall to the nucleus
which was what um
actually you know triggered the
investigation of the atom at the
beginning of the 20th century people
wanted to know why doesn't the electron
fall
to the nucleus and to this day we have
no explanation for that and i'll add
another one and that is why doesn't the
electron fly out of the atom
spontaneously what keeps it bound to the
proton or the nucleus or whatever
so this is the issue we have no
explanation for the atom and if you
don't have an explanation for the atom
meaning you don't have an atom to
explain electricity then you don't have
electricity you do not understand
electricity it's just as simple as that
okay so uh
you know we have no understand
mathematicians don't have any
understanding of electricity how about
light are we doing any better with light
well these are this is what you see for
light out there you see what waves and
particles
what are waves well there are a bunch of
vectors that are moving very scary stuff
you have these vectors which are
magnitude and direction and they're
shown as moving through space
okay so what we have is a number
that apparently is pointing i don't know
how numbers point but this is what
they're saying that we have values that
are pointing in some direction and these
values are pointing are moving sideways
absolutely scary stuff
and then particles well we cannot
explain with particles why uh light has
wave properties for example why that
particle is supposed to go up and down
and if it goes up and down what takes it
up what brings it down
so you know we don't we can't uh mimic
we cannot simulate
light with particles or with waves
both are dead in the water and so what
they did was you know essentially they
said um you know we're going to build
the
the new
the new model which is the wave packet
okay what is that well they try to blend
the wave with a particle
and so they said travels as a wave and
arrives and departs as a particle and
that's more or less the description they
have for the wave packet and that's what
they use can you illustrate a wave
packet for me absolutely not
roger penrose in his book one of his
books he put a
corkscrew and that's a professional
mathematician who just won a nobel prize
okay yeah so science is not an ongoing
process
at all
we just have to
answer these questions that's what a
physicist has to answer simply required
to explain mechanisms specifically
action at a distance you know uh you
have um
get this out of here
you have two bowls
let me get them here
here you have two balls
this is all you have to explain okay
this is the only issue remaining and
then we can all become extinct because
we have no more to investigate in
physics physics with this goes
at a dead end it's the end of physics
and that
is two particles
you don't like particles you like
planets two planets
or the earth and the moon or the sun and
the earth or whatever you want doesn't
matter
all you have to explain is action at a
distance
okay so in magnets as well if you say
this is one magnet this is another
magnet how does this one affect that one
that's all you got to explain that's the
only issue remaining it's the only issue
that no one has been able to explain two
thousand five hundred years once we
explain that the mechanism we're done
with physics forever there is no more
physics after that okay so let me repeat
that
two planets two particles two magnets
any any one that you want to select i
don't care you have to explain okay this
is it this is a million dollar question
worth two beers okay
how does this one affect this one
without any mediator
okay
and if you don't put a media here you're
using black magic
therefore you had better put a mediator
make it visible for us just so that we
can understand the mechanism
doesn't mean we're going to believe in
your theory
but you better put some kind of mediator
from here to there otherwise you're
doing black matching so if you're going
to do entanglement and you're going to
say that this particle instantly affects
this one you know like rotating in the
same direction one rotates opposite
direction i'm sorry when rotating
clockwise the other one rotating
counterclockwise this one affects this
one instantaneously irrespective of
distance
then you one here one atom here the
other one on in the andromeda galaxy 2.5
million light years away that's a
measure of distance okay driving at the
speed of light two and a half million
years that's what it would take to get
to andromeda and these people are saying
that when this one moves clockwise this
one moves automatically counterclockwise
and there's nothing in between them
and here you have the one planet and
another planet it turns out the moon or
for example the moon and the earth right
and the moon affects the tides of earth
and the earth affects
the uh the moon because it's not allowed
to leave the solar system
how does it do it instantaneously how
does it do it at all i mean any way you
want to explain it but hopefully there's
something that extends from the earth to
the moon from the moon to the earth
and magnet's the same thing you have
magnet attracting magnet hopefully you
put some physical object in between
there otherwise you're doing black magic
okay so that's the whole issue with uh
science and with physics
if you cannot explain that you have not
explained
physics and that's one of the issues
that the mathematic the only issue
really ultimately that the
mathematicians cannot explain have never
explained and will never explain uh if
if they
attempt to do it through equations
and they can run all the experiments
they want they're never going to figure
out what invisible intangible entity
mediates the transactions
and i don't know if i got through to you
with all that but that's what you gotta
that's what you gotta solve otherwise
you don't get the two beers okay
okay um
what else do we have here
yeah this is just a punch line on that
or the ending you know i say that you
know you have to tell
this follower who believes in all this
stuff he thinks we're doing fine with
science we have to define science and we
cannot use you know what we've had in
the past because none of those
definitions give us answers to these
questions they cannot tell us anything
about gravity they cannot tell us
anything about magnetism light
electricity the workings of the atom or
even the structure of the atom
none of these
definitions that we have today of
science you know from the 17th century
that's what we inherited specifically
experiments right and math obviously but
math already came from the greeks what
was new was experiments
and if you have an intangible invisible
entity what experiment are you going to
run in the lab to detect it to elucidate
you know its architectural or structural
nature
there is not you're just wasting your
time so you we have to define redefine
actually science you know rational
explanations that's what science is what
is physics rational explanations of uh
causes underlying uh mechanism i spelt
underlying in reverse
i hope you catch that okay math cannot
help decipher you know causes a
mechanism you can't do it with math and
math is just exclusively descriptions
that's all that math is good for math is
a language that can only describe it has
no power no authority no wherewithal to
explain okay a mechanism experiments
also cannot disclose invisible
intangible mediators
so it there's no purpose where you going
to the lab and say i'm going to run an
experiment i'm going to verify with an
experiment what are you going to verify
with an experiment here's the experiment
the only experiment you ever needed we
let go of the pencil watch it's very
dangerous very expensive okay you let go
the pencil and it falls down now all you
have to do is explain why the cause the
mechanism
what good is an equation what good is
running another experiment you want me
to do it again another experiment okay
let's do it again
and
that's the only experiment you ever
needed for gravity
so now you're not going to
elucidate the invisible intangible
entity by running experiments or doing
math that's why math and
experiments are not part of the
scientific method okay
because they've never helped us in the
last 400 years
and therefore neither matter experiments
aren't part of the scientific method as
it relates to physics okay causes and
mechanisms once we figure out action at
a distance discover the invisible
intangible meteors we are done with
physics we're through
we're finished we're done there's no
more physics after that because now we
understand how the universe works the
only part we cannot explain is actually
an action and distance
people in general can understand you
know one object hitting another one this
we can understand push you know more or
less we don't know how this guy moved
over there but we don't care we can
understand push because that's more or
less uh
self-explanatory you visualize say okay
surface to surface this one push that
one we understand push
what no one understands is pull because
for pull you need to put in mediator
okay and if you don't put a mediator
you're doing black magic that's how
simple it is
okay so a fellow criticizes uh put a
comment on that to me or thereabouts he
says you've got to be kidding some of
the greatest breakthroughs in science we
got thanks to math enough said
yeah matt cannot answer those questions
so this fall hasn't uh you know been
around long enough that's that's the
only problem he just peris the
establishment he doesn't understand what
the issues are no math cannot tell us
anything about the the cause of gravity
the mechanism of gravity the invisible
mediator of gravity for that you cannot
use any math whatsoever you just gotta
look back think you know and visualize
that's the only way okay and so this is
what we say is there a rational way to
do science
uh i presented this the other day yeah
there is uh you have to propose the
right approach okay and
you must ask what is it that the
scientific method is attempting to
achieve what is its purpose you know in
in the context of physics and the answer
cannot rely on tradition democracy you
know voting for uh
um you know
definition or um
what's the authority
you cannot rely on that you cannot say
well we've always done it this way and
this is what my teacher told me and no
none of that you have to
define it in a way that you can defend
your definition of science as it relates
to physics okay so this is not a matter
of opinion it's a matter of can you
defend your theory okay
and yeah we're saying that um
science to this date what we've been
doing for the last 400 years especially
what we've been doing the last 150 years
uh
is completely irrational the
explanations are all all completely
irrational not one of them survives
rationality why because why are they
irrational because they are in the
process they're in the habit or in the
practice of moving concepts around
they explain everything with concepts
they introduce a concept such as energy
or field or wave or plasma or any of
those which are abstract concepts and it
takes a mathematician to understand the
two years at least to understand why
those are concepts and not physical
objects okay
uh no i didn't
miss any word i i didn't put one in
there by mistake you know uh none of
those are objects time is not an object
ether is not an object energy is not an
object
field
force
none of those words charge you know none
of those words that the mathematicians
use qualify as objects in physics so you
cannot do physics you cannot do physical
interpretations with those concept
abstract mathematical concepts which is
what the mathematicians do